I'm always excited you listen if you've
ever seen me speak publicly you'll see
them nothing if not patriotic
you love I do love my home country yeah
yeah I always wondered about what your
kids thought about you becoming because
you like does that buy you more cachet
with the little ones or are they like
now put off of Pokemon because you're in
it no this is the weirdest thing this is
the first time in my life my kids have
been 100% psyched to see something I'm
in yeah maybe the trick is that they
haven't yet fully understood or put
together that it's me doing the voice my
daughter
James did say that I sound like she's
daddy you you sound like detective
Pikachu and I because the movie was
large for me the movie is largely shot
in motion capture I wasn't ever on set
so I never brought her on set she ever
actually saw me interacting with any of
these people or Pokemon so she doesn't
really know and I not gonna correct her
I'm just gonna let her see the movie and
then I'm gonna reveal right or one day
for in the future she'll just figure it
out I think she's gonna like I think
like five or ten minutes into the movie
she's gonna look over at me and go oh
you've done it you've done it this time
and what was the Blake's reaction when
when this role came your way um I don't
think she was anything beyond mildly
amused I don't you know there's wouldn't
what do you say you know what a movie
starts it's all just sort of like a
dream you know there's no kind of um
there's nothing to grab on to yeah so so
and particularly this movie which I
spent only three days on set and the
rest of the time was motion capture
performance which I capture all over the
world they would just come to whatever
said I was on ran yeah I recorded
Pikachu and um Abu Dhabi in Rome Canada
New York Spain all over the place yeah
so and so anywhere that you went you
just kind of had to be ready for it yeah
it was kind of like a team of five he
would come they'd set up a ton of really
high tech gear I would wear a tracking
suit and then we would put the facial
capture stuff around which is a bunch of
cameras on a helmet yeah and we just go
we just do it so and it's it sounds like
the easiest thing in the world but it's
probably not because these guys have to
lug all this stuff all crap halfway
across
a little bit but for me it was really
freeing like it's all imagination you
know I just throw eight hundred
different jokes or ideas up against the
wall and it would I would leave it to an
editor to sort out it was so you had a
lot of freedom just to kind of be you as
Pikachu yeah I don't think they wanted
me to be anything else so like I you
know when I first met with him I said
well what if you know he's kind of like
one was like hardened a sort of Colombo
kind of like New York City Bronx kind of
detectives when they were like yeah I'll
just do Ryan Reynolds great I can do
that yeah a scale of one to ten how deep
were you into the Pokemon over over the
decades or what I would say as about a
two because I'm not gonna be that guy
right now in this interview where I was
like oh please like like yeah Pokemon
was like was my religion I knew of it I
mean it's it the cultural impact of it
is is massive I mean it's a worldwide
phenomenon so I knew about it I didn't
know the nuance or the details like that
so I had to kind of take a crash course
and could you name a bunch of Pokemon if
I hypothetically put you on the spot for
20 seconds to see how many you could
name no really I you probably can't one
no I don't think I can do I'm gonna fail
at that miserably I mean I have my
favorites yeah I'm sore and squirtle and
Cool Hunter terror as I like yeah you
know yeah that's about it
well done thank you well listen we're
big fans obviously of yours and we can't
wait for the movie and we all have
Pokemon so we want to have this nice cuz
I own whoa that's a weird one isn't it
like your face on that right that's
super weird how to scare children under
five seconds I've got you IET Canada I
graphic that was legit like I mean this
is this is the best I could do this yeah
the most disturbing thing in the world
I think you should scrub this person's
laptop immediately there's evidence on
there I'm sure yeah cool
hey thanks thank you very much all right
pleasure to show the rest your time
enjoy that thank you
you